ouais
voyez par le coup sanglant
- donc pétale de sous-verre je suis un yatta collant
je pensais oh axiome tous les jours
Verity vous garantit un jet à
Rochelle ouais si une expérience Lakers of calc
à Rondo of X est un moyen de
traiter le véhicule comme sur Olivia  et
simplifiez xie yu's na elle a bien expliqué la
boîte via Oscar
envoyer MIDI à cheval ADIZ J'ai quitté la nouvelle
boîte aux lettres J'étudie en
désorientant Jésus il pourrait justifier ça
ne me manque pas passe papa dis donc - oh d'
accord - je nous pardonne
Yamato a bien sûr eu une sensation  ce que tu Mel
je ne t'ai jamais vaincu Mel je te vois un paquet
Chef Apache ce que je pense
que c'est notre dernière chance de s'amuser
pour la vie nous déchire
Olivia et tous nos amis vont au
Mexique parce que c'est leur dernière semaine de relâche
Olivia rencontre un gars  et il les invite
dans cet endroit désolé où nous jouons à
un jeu de vérité ou ose je vous mets au défi de
donner à Tyson un tour de danse pendant 30 secondes
tout le monde dans son enfance a
définitivement joué au jeu vérité quelles
sont vos intentions avec la nôtre douce
olivia mais dans  ce jeu de vérité ou d'action
les enjeux sont assez élevés j'avais besoin de
trouver quelqu'un avec des amis que je pourrais
inciter à venir ici je vous ai tous amenés
ici parce que je suis d'accord avec la
mort d'étrangers si cela signifie que je peux vivre ce que
diable le  le jeu est maudit d'accord où que
vous alliez, quoi que vous fassiez, il vous trouvera
bien le jeu trouvera votre secret le plus
sombre ou votre plus grande peur et
il l'utilisera contre vous
vérité ou défiez cette belle jeune femme ici
m'a défié de vous montrer mon  affaires tu
dois dire la vérité ou tu meurs tu fais
le défi ou tu meurs tu ne fous pas ça
ces défis et ces vérités
bouleversent la vie c'est effrayant de savoir que
cette chose est une vérité inévitable ce n'est
pas comme ça que ça marche
seul le jeu décide chéri  briser
la main d'Olivia tu dois le faire avoir l'air aussi
énervé que je le suis en ce moment il n'y a
aucun moyen que je te casse la main tu
n'as pas vraiment le choix
Dieu fais le nous avons tous peur de
quelque chose et ça joue absolument  sur
les peurs de tout le monde qu'est-ce qu'on obtient o  ut de
ce jeu vivant tu ne peux pas tu peux refuser
de jouer mais tu ne vas pas vivre pour voir
un autre jour c'est les seules mains à tous
les joueurs sont morts et tu es trans à
côté de
toi